coup de froid sur belfort la ville
préfecture n'en finit pas de perdre des
habitants selon l'insee
sa dernière population recensée
s'établit à 47 1656 habitants soit près
de 2500 habitants de perdus entre 2012
et 2017
une situation qui n'inquiète pas damien
meslot
pour le maire cette baisse est passagère
et serait dû à la destruction de tour
hlm dans certains quartiers comme les
résidences ou des glacis du château
nous sommes dans une opération de
restructuration nous avons fait des
choix politiques de détruire dans les
quartiers de l'habitat qui datait des
années 60 et qui n'étaient plus adaptés
pour reconstruire un certain nombre de
beaux logements en centre ville et cela
va commencer à produire ses effets dans
les années 2022 2023
une tendance qui s'explique aussi par le
départ de certaines familles en
périphérie foot de terrains
constructibles et par la baisse du
nombre moyen d'occupants par logement
mais pour certains c'est l'attractivité
de la ville qui est en cause selon
bastien photo conseiller municipal
d'opposition
il s'agit d'un décrochage historique et
pour lui le pire reste à venir
les chiffres qui sont publiés par
l'insee la de 47 1656 habitants ne
tiennent pas compte puisque les
conséquences ne sont pas encore visibles
du plan de licenciement chez general
electric
donc on est dans un véritable trou d'air
la question c'est comment on fait
redémarrer belfort parce que là on est
dans une logique de cercle vicieux si
belfort perd des habitants d'autres
communes de l'agglomération elle en
gagne à l'image de besson court of non
ou danjoutin